the biggest misconception about
redundancy
and perhaps challenge is a natural one
and it's that we all take it personally
redundancy is usually
just a reality where organizations are
having to
reorganize and rethink how they do
things the more you can
focus on what makes you brilliant and
then find the next possibility that
matches that brilliance the better
on average in the uk around 40 percent
of us will experience redundancy
at least once in our working lives and
in my nearly 20 years of work
it's already happened to me a few times
start with your strengths your strengths
are what make you distinctive and how
you add value at work
and research shows that when we use our
strengths we are six times more engaged
and generally more satisfied in our jobs
if you need some help spotting your
strengths try asking
friends family and people you've worked
with this question
what three words would you use to
describe me at my best
this gives you a quick insight into the
positive impact that you have on others
and once you know your strengths don't
forget to make sure they stand out on
your cv
and on your linkedin profile being made
redundant and searching for new
opportunities can be
tiring stressful and really overwhelming
at times
one useful technique for staying
optimistic is to record and reflect
on all your very small successes at the
end of each day for at least a week
write down one success that you've had
perhaps it was just finding the time to
go for a walk
or supporting a friend in some way or
writing your first blog post
even if you've had a tough day this
exercise helps us to reflect on
and recognize our positive progress
asking for help can feel hard so here
are a few ideas prompted by what i've
learned along the way
about what works and just as importantly
what doesn't
first don't apologize and be specific
about the help that you need
i remember being made redundant and
asking someone very senior for a career
chat
within the first minute of our meeting
she asked me so how can i help you
and i was so grateful for her time that
i hadn't really thought about a specific
answer to that question
and always avoid using words like sorry
and just in your messages and
conversations
it's important to be confident in asking
for the help that you need
second think about how you feel when
you're helping someone you're probably
flattered and enjoy the opportunity to
be useful
remember that's how other people feel
too and finally
if someone can't help you don't take it
personally there's no limit on help
so ask as many people as possible
choose the job where you'll grow the
most investing in learning is the most
important career choice you can make
this advice has really helped me to
focus less on what i sometimes describe
as shiny objects
like job titles or perks and prioritize
making decisions
based on working with people and at
places where i can learn the most
start with the end in mind you're 90 on
a park bench
looking back what matters i always
remember
amanda's advice in moments where i'm
feeling overwhelmed
fast forwarding to the future helps me
to be more pragmatic
and prioritize in the here and now run
your own race
it's easier than ever to compare our
careers to our family and friends and
colleagues
but if we fall into this trap we forget
that we're all motivated by different
things
one of the advantages of careers today
is that they can be as individual as we
all
are so we need to invest in and take
care of our own careers
i really hope this has been helpful and
very best of luck
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video